hello everyone this is june 2022 and
after rather long time i'm going to make
a video dedicated to the undergraduate
students specifically to the first year
students
my plan here is to share a few tips with
you as you transition to the second year
but before i can do that allow me to
take you on a short memory trip back to
november 2021. that was a time when i
had made a video sharing a few tips with
the students as they were beginning
their first year engineering journey now
although that video was made for
engineering students it turned out to
have a wonderful response positive
response not only from the engineering
students but from students from various
disciplines that comment section of the
video was filled with hopeful responses
hopeful remarks
a great amount of positivity
freshness great cheer and
a rather nice positive longing for what
lies ahead but
life and reality doesn't exactly
dance to the beat of youtube comment
section
six months have passed since then
and in this six months many things have
happened both good and bad happy and sad
but no matter what your situation is now
i commend you all i commend you all
really genuinely for having made thus
far
because
i want to put it publicly on record that
your particular batch the first year
batch as well as the badge just senior
to you have had it absolutely the worst
in living memory of all of us okay and i
really hope for all our sakes that your
children and your children's children
and for all generations to come never
have to face this
but this is the reality that you are in
the only good thing is that it is coming
to an end finally in the coming few
weeks your first year studies are going
to end and my hope is that you can
finally see the light at the end of the
proverbial tunnel
and as you end up first here and
transition to second year i believe that
you will get a very short summer
vacation of a few weeks at least here at
iit kharagpur the students are going to
get about a month holiday uh and in some
institutes i have learned that it is
even less than that maybe even two or
two weeks of holiday and in some cases
only just a few days of holiday
which is which is really really
unfortunate but i appreciate that
different institutes have different
constraints and they have to live with
that
but no matter
no matter how short a holiday you have
i'm going to share a few tips okay so
these tips are specifically targeted at
the first year students although i think
that the second year students who are
transitioning to third year will also
find it useful these tips mind you are
not going to add any points in your cv
okay these are general practical common
sense tips this is something to
help you sow the seeds of long-term life
benefits like genuine life benefits and
trust me on this when i say
that this is probably the
last
summer vacation the last genuine real
summer vacation that you're going to
have in a really really long time once
you go into your third year fourth year
once you get your job
you may get
some what is referred to as technically
summer vacation but you're still going
to end up you're still going to go
through the grind of it all okay so
enjoy this summer vacation no matter how
short it is uh savor it okay so let's go
to the tips we have to address the
elephant in the room which is that all
through these six months that you've
spent in your first year you have had to
make many sacrifices to forgo many
enjoyments and one of the foremost
enjoyments for this particular
generation i hope is to sacrifice if you
have done sacrifices that is uh on binge
watching shows from various kinds of
streaming services or maybe even on
television maybe some of you have uh
forgone are playing some video games to
a certain extent maybe some of you are
planning to unleash yourself on binge
watching these shows
and i can understand the temptation but
my advice to you is that
you can indulge yourself a little bit
but don't overdo it okay
there are better things to do as i will
discuss over here
so try to spend as much time as possible
away from screen you have spent
unprecedented amount of screen time
maybe starting even from your plus two
all throughout your first year before
the screen so try to spend as much as
time possible during the short summer
vacation away from the screen okay
whether it is the mobile phone screen or
the computer screen or the tv screen
okay invest this is my first tip to you
invest some actual
uh quality time
outside okay away from your screen away
from your computer get up from your
computer go outside meet with your
friends invest some quality time in
actual physical genuine social
interaction i would like to mention a
point here that especially for the
introverted students the pandemic has
been bad for all of us but
for the introverted students
they may have had
taken the pandemic
as a kind of excuse as an official
excuse to isolate them themselves even
more from social interactions because
they naturally don't feel very
comfortable with these kinds of
interactions and the pandemic just gave
them an excuse to isolate themselves
more okay so if that has happened it is
even more pertinent and necessary that
you try to get out of that comfort zone
of isolating yourself go out and meet
people meet some of your friends some of
your batch mates from school and note
that people who have had online classes
from your home this is your last real
chance to meet up with your school
friends okay your near and dear school
friends because now you'd be coming back
to campus or coming to campus rather my
next tip
would be that
maybe plan out a trip
with your family and friends now this is
rather commonplace advice
people go out on trips in uh these kinds
of vacations so what's new
uh is that
instead of relying on your parents to
plan out the trip
take a little personal responsibility
and you plan out the trip okay
consult with your parents of course uh
regarding everyone's availability and so
on but plan out the trip yourself this
will give you an immense amount of
satisfaction okay you'll have the fun
you'll also have
a chance to grow up a little bit as an
adult okay so this kind of taking
responsibility for oneself as over a
group this is something that is going to
help you in great state uh stand you in
great state once you actually go to your
campus my next step is that you invest
some time on your personal development
what i mean is that personal development
which is beyond the scope of your
engineering and science or whatever
other academic discipline that you may
be in so for example many of you may be
interested in playing sports and games
and that is wonderful
now at the same time if you are only
playing sports and games as a side
activity from your academics and maybe
not spending any time at all
or reading some other books okay and i
and by this i mean
actual fiction uh some kind of
serious newspaper articles maybe
non-fiction books something to expand
your mind okay then please start doing
that immediately and if you're the sort
of person conversely who like to spend a
lot of time with books with outside
books like
non-academic books you like to read
fiction um and i'm guessing that this
will be the kind of people who are
more like me slightly introverted uh
don't like to mix up with others friends
don't like to play games and so forth so
on and so forth
for these kinds of students my personal
advice is that try to get out of your
comfort zone leave your books for a
little while and try to go out and play
now in the very short summer vacation
that you have it may not be a practical
idea to find a group of friends mix up
with them and start playing so what you
can do is at least for the sake of
physical activity maybe indulge in some
kind of exercises yourself okay this is
this will bring immense health benefits
to you and referring back to that
earlier video i made in november 2020
one i had pointed out that health will
be one of the major uh things to look
out for for your success in your
academics okay so this will be a very
very good investment in your personal
development and please also note that
this advice regarding physical
activities about playing games uh is not
restricted to boys i urge all the girl
students also to engage in some kind of
physical activity you may even
just ride the bicycle okay or if you
have a group of friends uh go and play
with them
okay
i know in a city environment this may be
easier said than done but i'm sure
you're all intelligent boys and girls
you can figure out a way for this okay
but please take this very very seriously
i would also like to point out here that
uh going back to that advice regarding
reading
or reading non-academic books
uh see this is
like
a habit which you have to build over
time okay like overnight you cannot
start reading books uh so one tip one
starting tip if you're really not
accustomed to reading books is that
don't try to start read reading books
by taking by picking up something very
heavy
okay it's not going to work out it's
going to absolutely backfire you lose
all interest in reading so my personal
tip is that you start reading
by taking up something very very
interesting on something which you find
a great amount of interest maybe pick up
a very easy kind of thriller okay it's
almost reads like a movie
or
some kind of detective story which is
very enjoyable
i personally enjoy this very much
so agatha christie arthur common doyle
their classics you can go with them or
maybe any modern
techno thriller also but start with
something which actually interests you
next tip is regarding writing now this
is a very very serious tip
you see
this particular generation of students
your generation of students i'm seeing
and this is rather unfortunate that you
are slowly losing this ability to write
in long form and not just your batch
actually this has happened to all of us
many of us who used to be able to write
long form are slowly slowly losing this
habit unless our professional duties uh
demand of us to write long form
and mind you in five years or ten years
time
this
ability to write and write in a
professional way will be like a
superpower for your generation
as your generation starts to climb up
the professional ladder in in that five
or ten years time okay so please be
very very mindful of this requirement
okay no matter what kind of field that
you are going to go in especially for
those who have any interest in going for
higher studies this ability to write in
a very clear effective professional way
is going to be of utmost importance
and please note
that
writing is
much much harder than reading
okay reading is an active hobby
but writing is a much much proactive
heavy habit than reading
you actually have to invest your your
brain your hand
together your entire body in sync for
writing so this is not something which
you can pick up on a whim overnight i've
seen a lot of students when they're
going for higher studies they have to
prepare for gre and exams like that and
they start preparing maybe a month or
two before their exams uh for these
kinds of activities for compositions for
essay writings and whatnot and uh
it's it's it's like a crash course kind
of thing it doesn't really help so if
you start early if you slowly slowly
build up this thing it is it is actually
like a muscle like it's like going to
the gym to build muscles it doesn't
happen overnight and no matter
what app you may be using what shortcuts
you may be trying to use it is not going
to
help you okay you have to have to go
through the grind of actually building
this habit
a little by little every day every week
over the years okay
so
my suggestion again just like in the
case of reading is that start small okay
so now what you can do probably is that
uh the easiest thing to write is
something autobiographical like about
yourself everyone likes to talk about
themselves which is why there is such a
proliferation of vlogging on youtube
okay everyone likes to talk about
themselves you don't have to do that but
you can always journal journal means
keep a diary write on it every night
it's the easiest form of writing trust
me on this i've done this myself when i
was quite young in my high school i
started writing diaries uh
and then
it actually develops your writing muscle
and then
if you find actually that you that you
like writing you will you will yourself
find yourself writing
randomly some articles maybe even a
poetry a poem or a short story uh who
knows
where it can take you okay so uh
so try to pick up this habit
now
i've shared a few things with you please
note that
as i've said earlier
none of these none of this is going to
give you any immediately visible
benefits in the short term
okay so in each of these things whether
you are going out and interacting
genuine physical interaction with social
interaction with others or maybe
planning out a trip
for traveling
uh with your parents and friends family
members or reading or writing
apparently there will be no benefit in
the short term you may not see anything
now
it will take time for you to see the
benefits over the years so
this is a long game okay
this is these are the things these are
the ingredients for the success uh
in the long game of life
all right so be mindful of that don't
get frustrated uh by small hiccups here
and there and over the course of this
short summer vacation uh
i mean if you are being too ambitious
and try to do all of these things you
will probably
fall flat on your face maybe pick up one
or two of these things and try to do
them well and
the biggest
thing that you can
do
for your future self is to actually pick
up one of these things these are like
habit forming activities and actually
make a habit out of them by sustaining
them this is very very important it is
very easy to read just one off book it
is very easy to write
a diary for a few days and then give up
on it
it is very easy to just go out and meet
a friend
just for the cake of it
but to make a habit out of each of these
things that require sustained
conscious effort on your part
okay it requires absolutely conscious
and sustained effort sustained means
carried over
week after week day after day
okay so unless
you
are very conscious about it very serious
about it it's not going to help you it's
not going to form a habit and you're not
going to get the benefit out of it and
my my hope is that
once you pick up maybe one or two of
these habits over the course of this
short summer vacation you are going to
continue
uh
being involved with this activity with
this habit uh over the course of the
next few years
and then maybe this will be a key
ingredient to your future success so
just like
that earlier comment section of that of
that earlier video in november 2021 was
filled with hope i want to end this
video on this
on this
note of hopefulness and good cheer and
all the very best to you
all of you for your final tests and
assignments and
wrapping up of the first year all the
very best